particularly in this context woke people
are using certain words
they they don't traffic in the normal
meanings of words when we look them up
in the dictionary like equity would be
another a perfect word that's totally
misunderstood and my kids go to public
school here in oregon or my my my
daughter my son graduated
every email equity equity equity equity
equity equity equity do you know what
equity means
you're asking me ask somebody in your in
in your film crew over there
david what is equity here today well
this is the seventh time but what does
equity mean david uh to have a piece of
something yeah like uh no no not equity
of a company equity as an equity uh uh
uh in in uh
in in society equity
oh i would i mean that's i don't know
you wouldn't know in society to be well
that's what they're talking about it's
not equity like you're a piece of the
company all right so this is wonderful
this illustrates the point
the vast majority of people have no idea
what the word equity means and you know
the guy that you're going to fire after
this episode
he's he's
absolutely he's absolutely correct
they've changed the meanings of that
word so equity means
to make up for this is even kennedy's
definition uh or a part of his world
view that feeds into the definition
to make up for past injustices we need
future injustices and future and
presence and justices so if people have
been to systematically discriminated
against because they're you know
gay or trans or
black we need to
fix that by discriminating against
people who don't have those
characteristics the other thing to think
about with equity is you want equality
of outcome not a quality of opportunity
that's why the governor of new york for
example has
our ap classes
yeah well they're they're getting rid of
the talented gifted
programs for kids because the idea is
it's an equity-based system it's not
it's the opposite of equality but the
only reason i mention this at all is
because
one of the reasons that woke has made
such inroads is that in in you know when
you ask david most people don't know
what these words mean and so we're
basing policies educational policies for
our kids in k-12 systems for our
judiciary for our media we're basing
these for the aclu the southern poverty
law center all of these things are now
a value that suddenly sprung into
existence that nobody heard of five
years ago and if they did it was in the
context of finance now who's driving
this though who's driving these
initiatives who's the mastermind behind
this
today because it seems like it's sudden
that this happened in the last five ten
years
yeah that's that's correct it started in
the university system and it leaked out
of the university system i i want to say
two things
you remember how shocked you were at the
of people very much so yes okay so so i
think the problem is that people get way
too caught up in oh this is a right left
thing or conservatives or republicans
forget about that forget about that
let's say let's say that that the people
in there were mormons
let's say that 99 of the people at a
university were mormons
do you think that that
and it was a liberal arts university
yeah
as opposed to you know stem or civil
engineering or math
do you think that those kids would get
an as good of an education from that as
they would if they were intellectual
diversity were there some mormons and
some muslims and some atheists and some
christians
of course you're going to have more
you know if you have diversity if you
have a uh
sure
and so part of the that's part of the
problem part of the problem is that
you're correct intellectual diversity
benefits our kids it benefits our
democracy it benefits our society but
when you hear the word diversity which
is a very very common word now it
what they mean is two things they mean
intellectual homogeneity they mean an
environment in which everybody thinks
the same and has a certain set of
beliefs but has superficial
characteristics
yeah but but i i guess what i want to
know is do you know who drove these
things like who is driving these
initiatives like yeah and and then and
then next what's the master plan because
you're not going to be able to push this
for too far there's going to be pushback
by people on the opposing side that
they're just not going to take it
eventually so who's driving this and why
okay so that's a
separate question so
we've identified the problem we've seen
how it that
here's what happens so kids go into the
university system yeah they're taught by
people who believe this and these people
are true believers okay not all of them
because they've created a culture of
fear so anybody who speaks up against it
is a bigot is a homophobic racist
misogynist is a nazi in some cases
and so
so they've they have jobs for life it's
called tenure they teach people
you know basically what are moral
conclusions they test them on it
three four five six years later these
kids get out they go to they get out of
the university they go into the
workforce because they have degrees then
they occupy positions of administration
management etc and they bring these
ideas with them the pronoun ideas the
safe spaces the trigger warnings the
microaggressions
the nucleation point where this all
starts is the university system all of
it so if you like this sort of short
clip from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]
you